in our societies we use the word success
a lot and we think we know just what it
means money status fame and power but
take a look in the dictionary and things
start to look thankfully a lot more
complicated because success is in truth
rather more neutral and less value
lately than we tend to assume it just
means doing anything well excelling at
something and that might encompass a lot
of different activity learning hundred
meters before selling your app for a lot
of money okay but also stranger less
heralded things like listening a lot
very attentively to a child or being
extremely kind to strangers or filling
your mind with interesting ideas in
associations or knowing just when to put
an arm around someone when it's too much
for them people who triumph here are
also big success stories no one can be
successful at everything whatever they
tell us it's almost impossible to
succeed with career and the family or
with popularity and integrity there are
always sacrifices it's great to be
successful it's even better to make sure
you followed your own distinctive and
not necessarily always obvious path to
the success that can truly fulfill you
you
you